[Musique]
c'est un parc c'est une rue c'est une
statue c'est la première femme
importante de l'histoire de Montréal sa
co-fondatrice j'amance elle est pas
mariée elle n'est pas religieuse si elle
n'est pas Marielle n'est pas veuve donc
elle n'a pas de statut social on va dire
à l'époque puis elle est capable de
braver d'aller de se dépasser d'aller au
bout de son élan de son engagement de
son talent pour finalement
fonder un hôpital et finalement fonder
une ville tout comme Jeanne de Mons la
réalisatrice Annabelle Loyola est
originaire de l'angle en Champagne et la
consacré trois films à la fondatrice de
l'Hôtel-Dieu et à son rêve pour le
nouveau monde c'était tout un projet un
projet humaniste un projet où il n'y
aurait pas d'inégalité sociale un projet
utopique et finalement j'annonce va
travailler toute sa vie donc pour
essayer de préserver les valeurs de ce
de ce projet là
[Musique]
je pense quand même que dans les valeurs
sociales qu'on défend à Montréal les
valeurs bienveillantes les soins
gratuits quand même aussi ça vient quand
même de jeunes masse en particulier en
plus l'accès aux services sociaux
ça je pense qu'il y a vraiment ça dans
l'ADN de Montréal et ça vient je crois
en partie de ces trois femmes là
350 ans plus tard les traces de
jademence sont encore nombreuses dans la
ville et sa mémoire bien vivante ici
Nabil Alexandre Chartier Radio-Canada
Montréal